Hang onto your wands because Harry Potter
is back!
Well … sort of.
Our favorite Boy Wizard isn't gracing the
big screen again, but his Wizarding World
has expanded, shedding some light on one of
the series' previously little-known characters:
Newt Scamander.
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them introduces
a fuller version of the guy previously best
known in the Potter universe for writing a
wizarding textbook.
And while the new series starter introduces
a distinct time, setting, characters, and
even vocabulary elements, there were some
subtle nods to the Harry Potter faithful you
might've missed.
And of course, let's not forget the magic
words: spoilers ahead.
Making a name
The biggest tie-in between Scamander and the
Potter universe — well, apart from being
a wizard, of course — is the fact that he
once wrote the book on magizoology that would
later be taught at Hogwarts.
Fantastic Beasts takes place long before Newt's
anthology would become a part of Hogwarts'
curriculum, so it was something of a nod to
the Potter realm that Newt's new gal Tina
gives its manuscript the name we all know.
That tiny-giant suitcase
The fact that Newt's suitcase had a limitless
interior size was certainly a callback to
things we'd seen in the Harry Potter series
before.
Consider how massive the Weasleys' Quidditch
World Cup tent was on the inside.
The visual element of the attache being opened
by prying claws too, seemed like a distinct
wink to that sassy The Monster Book of Monsters
that tormented Harry in Prisoner of Azkaban.
Hufflepuff pride
Even though he's no longer in good standing
within the halls of Hogwarts, Newt Scamander
obviously doesn't hold anything against his
old house, as evidenced by the Hufflepuff-colored
scarf tucked away in his briefcase.
"The best wizarding school in the world is
Hogwarts."
"Hogwash."
It's a good thing he's not bitter towards
his old institution, because we know his future
grandson, Rolf, is due to marry Hogwarts'
resident weirdo, Luna Lovegood down the line.
Quidditch quip
Quidditch was a beloved aspect of the wizarding
world throughout the Harry Potter series,
and Newt makes a small reference to the sport
when he's asked whether he's a seeker.
His response?
He's "more of a chaser, really."
That, of course, is a reference to his choice
of field position.
But perhaps if he had spent more time seeking
the Golden Snitch, it would've better prepared
him for the beast-grappling duties in this
installment.
Merlin's beard!
Even though American muggles are called "no-majs"
and there's plenty of other new terminology
to take in during Fantastic Beasts, there's
one turn of phrase that's a direct quote of
a line from the Harry Potter films: "Merlin's
beard!"
Where've you heard that before?
"Merlin's beard!"
There are also some familiar spells and wizarding
entryways, and this floating apple that eats
itself in front of the boy is as direct a
wink to Potter as they come.
Behold, the Niffler
The niffler might be new to the big screen
with Fantastic Beasts, but the adorable mole-duck-porcupine-mix
creature has long existed in the written realm
of magic.
Although the fantastic beast never made the
cinematic cut for Goblet of Fire, he gets
more than adequate screen time in Fantastic
Beasts.
There are other creatures who'd been mentioned
before but only made their screen debut in
Fantastic Beasts — including the size-shifting
Occamy and the disappearing Demiguise — but
the niffler is the real adorable hero of this
movie.
Dumbledore before
We didn't get to see our favorite headmaster
in Fantastic Beasts, but he did get a major
mention that proves he's alive and well as
this movie unfolds.
"Thrown out of Hogwarts for endangering human
life."
"That was an accident."
"With a beast.
Yet one of your teachers argued strongly against
your expulsion.
Now, what makes Albus Dumbledore so fond of
you?"
We can probably expect to actually see him
show up in the next installments of this series,
because there's another important character
coming into play as well that he'll have a
lot to do with...
Gellert Grindelwald 2.0
Polyjuice Potion impersonations ran rampant
throughout the Harry Potter series, so perhaps
the big twist in Fantastic Beasts — that
is, that Gellert Grindelwald had disguised
himself as Percival Graves throughout most
of the events of the movie — shouldn't have
been a surprise.
But the reintroduction of Grindelwald does
set the stage for some interesting character
history to come, especially when it comes
to Professor Dumbledore.
In the final Harry Potter movies, we learned
that the pair once worked together to recover
the Deathly Hallows in hopes of making the
world a better place, but their friendship
soured after Grindelwald began dabbling in
the Dark Arts.
Their duel to come will be one for the ages.
Lestrange family history
The Lestrange family became a major part of
the mayhem that arose at Lord Voldemort's
end, but Fantastic Beasts proves there was
more to their backstory than we might've guessed.
Before Bellatrix and Narcissa carried the
family into the Dark Lord's corner, there
was Leta.
Leta LeStrange doesn't get much discussion
in the first Fantastic Beasts movie, but we
do find out she was a former friend-slash-flame
of Newt's — who apparently betrayed him.
Count on her to come back and have some part
in Gellert Grindelwald's attempt to establish
a new world order for sure.
The Deathly Hallows
If there's one thing that could not be hidden
during Fantastic Beasts it's the symbolism
of the Deathly Hallows.
In the movie, Grindelwald, posing as Graves,
gives our new pal Credence a Deathly Hallows
necklace, much like the ones we'd seen before
in the Harry Potter movies.
This is also a clear reminder that the Deathly
Hallows are going to be a big part of the
battle to come.
"I wanna be a wizard!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!